oui c'est la première première fois que
Kev avait frappé depuis le mois de juin
et c'est la première fois que le centre
centre a été touché et c'est la première
fois pour moi personnellement que j'ai
cru prudent de mettre une ensemble
balistique en étant dans le centre de la
capitale c'est parce que le maire
vitaliclichko a mis encore de tous les
québecs en disant que le menace n'est
pas encore écarté l'alerte à la bombe
est encore en vigueur le maire a appelé
à tous les habitants de la capitale de
se rendre aux abris beaucoup de qui vont
je le vois autour de moi n'ont pas fait
attention à cet appel il y a encore
beaucoup de gens qui marchent dans les
rues même si les travaux dans ma rue
juste à côté ont cessé pour le moment et
dans la station de métro derrière moi il
y a un assez grand groupe de personnes
qui s’est rendu dans cette station de
métro pour se mettre à l'abri pour le
moment les trains de métro ne circulent
pas on a un chiffre pour le nombre de
victimes sur l'attaque qui a touché le
parc shephten dans le centre-ville 8
personnes ont trouvé la mort c'est
vraiment un parc il y a juste à côté une
université ce n'est pas très loin du QG
des services de sécurité ukrainienne spa
mais ce n'est pas si près quand même
c'est à quelques centaines de mètres et
il y a eu des frappe plusieurs autres
endroits de la capitale aussi y compris
sur un pont piéton qui était un pont où
les gens seront été pour faire des
selfies il y a une belle vue sur la
ville il est difficile d'imaginer un
cible avec moins de significations
militaire ou en termes d'infrastructures
critiques mais il faut croire que des
objets d'infrastructures critiquent ont
été ciblées aussi notamment en
périphérie de la ville vous le
démerzilinski au moment où vous exprimez
lui aussi est en train de de communiquer
selon lui la Russie est en train de
bombarder l'infrastructure énergétique
de l'Ukraine les civils sont la deuxième
cible un mot peut-être de Vladimir pout
qui est accusé hier les services secrets
ukrainien d'avoir commis un acte
terroriste en organisant l'explosion qui
a partiellement détruit le pont de
Crimée lui qui réunit aujourd'hui son
Conseil de sécurité pour faire le point
pour la Russie le pont qui relie la
Crimée
occupé à la Russie est un objet
d'infrastructure civile pour l'Ukraine
et c'est partenaires occidentales ce
n'est clairement pas le cas puisque
c'est par ce pont que transit une très
grande partie du matériel militaire
russe pour se rendre en Crimée et
ensuite dans le sud de l'Ukraine où les
contre-offensives ukrainiennes pour
essayer de reprendre la région de Herson
une grande partie de laquelle reste
occupée continue alors il y a une très
grande différence d'opinion mais quand
on voit la Russie bombardée un pompier
tout à Kiev si c'est une retaliation
pour le bombardement d'un pont qui est
clairement à une valeur stratégique
c'est je pense que il est clair à tout
le monde que les deux objets ne sont pas
vraiment comparables l'interprétation
que les Ukrainiens que je vois sur les
réseaux sociaux et avec qui je parle ici
à Kiev c'est vraiment que il y a une
décision de la Russie d'essayer de
terroriser la population de l'Ukraine
avec ses et puis dans l'ouest du pays
effectivement il semblerait que c'est
l'infrastructure de l'approvisionnement
en électricité qui a été touché des
pénuries sont constatées à le vif et à
terme
à l'heure